[Music]
thank you
good afternoon everyone thanks for
coming in hopefully you had you all had
a chance to take a break grab some lunch
AI is solving a lot of problems I'm
hoping one of these days it will solve
the post-lunch sleepiness problem
so with that my name is and I lead the
product management team for Google Cloud
I have couple of co-presentatives with
me I'll let them introduce themselves
before we jump in hi Reza rockney I'm
developer Advocate working for the
dataflow team at Google
hi I'm Kong Tran I'm a ml engineer from
Etsy
okay I figured out how this works
fantastic thanks gentlemen I'll call you
on stage for your sections
um
so before I jump in let me quickly give
you an overview of what we plan to cover
today I'm hoping to kick it off with a
little bit of an overview of the kind of
business problems that users like you
are interested in solving we call them
real-time intelligence you may be
calling it with a different name so
we'll do a little bit of context setting
talk through those business kind of
business problems and why it matters
I'll then give you a high level overview
of the kind of data architecture you
need in place to enable those use cases
I'll then have Reza come over talk
through in detail about many of the
capabilities that we have in the product
that will help you implement those use
cases we'll then have
we'll then have Kang join us on stage uh
we'll do a you know q a totally
unrehearsed you a lot of Believers when
we tell you that we'll do a q a where
Kang will share this experience at Etsy
implementing these use cases and then
finally time permitting I'll do a quick
Roundup of some of the latest and
greatest capabilities in data flow
so with that let's get started so let's
talk a little bit about the use cases so
when I talk to users like you the
potential that streaming data and
machine learning has in being able to
drive transformational changes in your
business is abundantly clear
interaction that your mic Services have
every interaction that your iot devices
have
the engagement that you have with your
users maybe your employees vendors
suppliers so on and so forth creates a
lot of meaningful data
if you have the ability to gather all of
that get meaning out of that data and
drive insights now you have the ability
to build new transformational business
capabilities or go build new delightful
experiences for it for your end users
that puts most relevant information and
actions at their fingertips when they
need it
we can see this examples in all
Industries and verticals I five
customers in healthcare that are
implementing use cases like real-time
patient monitoring
fraud detection when it comes to
Insurance we're all familiar with use
cases on the retail side be it things
like cart upsell product recommendations
or customer 360. and on the other end of
the spectrum something like
manufacturing and iot which in many ways
in fact kicked out the streaming data
Revolution you have use cases like
predictive maintenance supply chain
management so on and so forth
so we've talked about the use cases
let's talk a little bit about the kind
of data architecture that you need in
place to support these use cases
you know traditionally you know a lot of
data analytics and machine learning was
batch driven you ran you know batch ETL
processes maybe you landed once a day
once hour you got data from your
operational systems your transactional
systems mostly SQL databases you know
you run an ETL process took that your
data lake or your data warehouse and
then you had you know machine learning
feature extraction happening batch
training happening batch prediction and
so forth so on and so forth what this
allowed you to do is get insights from
batch data or historical data do
predictions store them up maybe you had
a nosql database where you where you had
all your predictions stored and then at
the time of serving you had your serving
systems look that up now this is going
to continue to exist right there's a
whole bunch of use cases that needs this
architecture this architecture is
sufficient we are going to continue to
see this
but for the kind of real-time use cases
that we talked about in the previous
slide you need to move to an
architecture where you're able to do
things like
real-time real-time features you know
some call it online features or
streaming features you need to be able
to do depending on the use case
real-time predictions or real-time
inferencing
so let's talk a little bit about how you
get there
I hopefully by the end of this I would
have figured out which is move forward
and which is backwards
okay so the first first step for
streaming is of course you know obvious
you need to have streaming data in place
right no surprises we're not going to go
on the details of the messaging systems
you know I suspect a lot of you are
familiar with things like Cloud pop sub
which is our partition list Cloud scale
messaging platform you also have Kafka
anyway the first step is to get your
Upstream systems to ingest data into one
of these right so once you have data in
um you know Pub sub or Kafka you can
start to do a lot of interesting things
with it
now very similar to the batch ETL world
where the data coming in from your
transactional systems is not ready for
analytics or machine learning the same
is true for streaming data as well
you need a mechanism by which you're
able to take that raw data in your
streaming system or in your messaging
system
process it you know you may be enriching
it just cleaning it or conforming it to
a specific schema or you're doing more
interesting things like streaming you
know feature extraction but you need a
stream processing platform in some cases
you could go roll your own system but
there is a lot of underlying plumbing
and infrastructure that you need to take
care of it
products like data flow and open source
products like Apache flank solve that
problem for you these platforms give you
an you know SDK higher level SDK a
mapreduce based SDK that allows you to
just focus on the data processing task
at hand and not worry about the
underlying infrastructure
Okay so we've solved that problem we now
know how to process the stream and you
know extract information from it do
things like enrichment
is that sufficient right so now you've
got you know data you can make sense of
that data now you need to figure out how
you go from processing to intelligence
now there are a lot of things that go
into that but there are three things
that we've observed in working with a
lot of customers
so one even when you're doing streaming
machine learning you have a need to
leverage batch data now that may be just
for you know backfilling things it may
be for you're filling gaps in your data
in some cases you're enriching your
streaming data and in other cases your
machine learning use case may need a
combination of streaming features as
well as batch features
the second challenge that we have seen
is you need a way a scalable way for you
to incorporate inferencing into your
streaming data processing you may be
doing local inferencing or remote
inferencing there are some trade-offs
involved we are not going to go into the
details of that today I do have couple
of use case or architecture slides that
I'll show you but there are some
interesting trade-offs involved and
we've seen the need where customer want
to start with local inference saying but
move to you know remote predictions and
go the other way as well
and then lastly you know one of the
defining attributes of real-time
intelligence is the ability to take
actions without having humans in the
loop
right traditionally with bi you got all
the data you got analytics and then you
had a dashboard you had a human look at
it maybe once a week once a month and
two day sessions with real-time
intelligence you want to get to a state
where you know the machine is making
this you know getting insights making
decisions and activating that now that
means that you need to have an ability
to have those insights reach your
Downstream systems it could be again a
messaging system it could be your
serving system or your transactional
system
so that's where something like data flow
comes into play right I suspect a lot of
you are familiar with data flow but for
those of you that are not familiar I'll
give you a quick overview data flow is
you know you know Google's Cloud native
uh data processing technology both for
batch and streaming data processing
it uses something called Apache beam
which is the SDK for defining your
streaming and batch data pipelines both
of these are based on a technology
called Flume that Google uses internally
for all of its big data processing needs
anyway so dataflow is a serverless you
know service that executes your
streaming and batch data processing
pipelines
Apache beam SDK gives you a and Kong
will cover some of this on why they
chose Apache beam and data flow gives
you a developer friendly SDK that allows
you to Define your data processing
Pipelines
there are a lot of things about these
two that we don't have time to go into
but I want to highlight three
capabilities that makes it uniquely
suited for real-time intelligence
the first is the fact that both the SDK
and the servers support unified batch
and stream processing Reza when he talks
through his section we'll show you some
code samples that show how it is easy to
switch from batch to streaming but you
have one SDK one technology to do both
batch and streaming and more importantly
you could have one pipeline that handles
both batch and streaming data
the second aspect I talked about how you
need to be able to connect to your
Downstream systems to activate insights
so that's where having robust support
for bi-directional Io comes into play
and then lastly
which is what Reza is also going to talk
about in detail having a set of out of
the box ml capabilities means you're not
Reinventing the wheel you're not going
through the tile of writing a lot of
boilerplate code that that uses best
practices and things like that so you
have out of the box capabilities that
makes it easy for you to quickly get
started and just focus on the Core
Business Logic on your site
so this is our favorite plop data flow
into the diagram that we saw earlier
this is our look now this may be a
little bit abstract so let's double
click and look at like few examples few
actual examples that customers have
implemented so this is from a telecom
customer of mine that has implemented uh
Network intrusion detection use case
based on using anomaly detection
techniques
so to do that the Angels logs Network
logs from their on-prem systems their
real-time data comes in through Kafka
and Pub sub their historical data comes
to Google Cloud Storage they have a data
flow pipeline that then inches both of
that data does things like feature
extraction and real-time predictions and
in this case the model was local to the
data flow job
uh they also leverage something like
Cloud DLP API so that they can
de-anonymize or anonymize the data to
remove Pi information from their locks
to make regulatory requirements they're
allowed to remove pii from anything that
powers their ml algorithms so given the
flexibility of data flow they are able
to do that
now contrasting
is a different example where the
customer was doing fraud detection in
this case they used a booster trees
model that was hosted in vertex AI for
various reasons like you know
flexibility and being able to manage the
model independent of the data pipeline
the model itself was hosted in vertex AI
Pipeline and the data flow job or the
data flow pipeline called into vertex AI
for doing predictions
now with that I'm gonna have a Reza come
over join us and walk through some of
the capabilities in the product that is
going to make it a lot more easier to
build use cases like these
thank you and see if I can figure out
the clicker
no wrong way
there we go uh hey everyone thanks Shan
so let's take a look at the role of
dataflow in this flow here
um the first thing the data flow in the
middle of the service has to do is it
needs to read from our source
we will then need to do some
pre-processing of that data and then we
will pass that pre-sources data to a
machine learning model in the first part
of this talk we're going to mainly
concentrate on where you have got a
pre-built model that you're going to
pull onto the data flow service for
local inference
we would normally have a post-processing
process so you would take the inferences
maybe join it with some other
information before you activate it at
the other end now the things that we're
going to need to do to it for this
obviously the
there we go obviously the data flow
service which is the fully managed
environment which is spinning up the
workers and executing the the work that
we described for that data flow service
to know what to do you're going to have
to build your pipeline within its SDK
which is uses the open source Apache
beam SDK for those of you who may not be
familiar with Apache beam we're going to
spend a couple of minutes just looking
at Apache beam and how you would build a
pipeline
so beam relies on a few core Primitives
that has lets us build up our pipeline
first of all it's a p-collection a
parallel collection of immutable objects
of the same type this is the data that
we are going to do our Transformations
on for the Transformations themselves we
have our P transform parallel transform
allows us to process the data within the
P collections creating new collections
of course this is all done in parallel
and at scale finally we need a way of
putting all this together for this we're
going to use the pipeline primitive so
here the pipeline is a directed acyclic
graph of computation which tells the
system how the P transforms and the P
collections are interacting with each
other
to bring it to life we're just going to
put together first of all these simple
batch Pipeline and then we'll make it
streaming so let's imagine that you have
physical stores and some online stores
which both generate files that we want
to do some processing on there's some
sales information we want to do some
sales analytics so first of all we would
need to read those files
um to do that we're going to make use of
the Python SDK here the p designates a
pipeline object and the pipeline pipe
operator means apply this transformation
to the pipeline so here we're applying
the read from text transform to the
pipeline generating our store sales and
online sales P collections next we're
going to use a primitive from beam to
bring it all together so this is the
flatten operator essentially this takes
2p collections with data types of the
same type and brings them together into
a single P collection
next we're going to do analytics now the
details of this doesn't matter
essentially it's just going to find the
top sales values
after we've done the analytics we then
want to Output the results to a Sync
here we're going to make use of bigquery
sync which is bigquery IO right to
bigquery
so with this we've built a batch
pipeline how do we now change it to a
streaming pipeline as Shan said earlier
beam was from the outset built to be
both batch and streaming so we don't
have to touch our business logic but we
do have to add one more primitive and
that's the window primitive so because
the data is continuously arriving we
need to actually know how to do the
computations when to Output a result and
for that we use the window primitive
which essentially subdivides a p
collection into timestamps
so let's change our pipeline so now at
the top rather than reading from files
we're going to read from Google Cloud
Pub sub of course this could be Kafka so
we now got a continuous stream of
information flowing through and if
you'll note just before our business
logic we've applied the window into uh
transform this is just creating those
fixed windows of 10 seconds which means
we're going to get continuous output
every 10 seconds that is then written to
bigquery okay so now how do we turn this
piece of analytics here into a machine
learning model so we've built a trained
model and we now want to use that for
the inference rather than simple
statistics here well if we were to do
this with The Primitives of beam and
there are many more than the ones I
described of course and you wanted to do
it in production there's actually quite
a lot of work to do so first of all
given model sizes we need to make sure
we share them efficiently across the
threads on the worker this is a
streaming pipeline we need to make sure
that bad data is not only preserved by
using a deadly letter q but also doesn't
clog up your streaming pipeline we need
to make sure that any pre and post
processing that is done on the model is
encapsulated within your model object so
you don't get training serving SKU we
need to make sure that when a new model
arrives in your streaming pipeline it is
quickly updated so all of this sounds
like a lot of code and far more work
than just a few lines in your streaming
pipeline luckily for us our data flow
Engineers have been working on adding
things to being known as a turnkey
transform the idea behind the turnkey
transform is rather than you as
developers having to take building
blocks to generate your goal we provide
a single line of code a single transform
and you provide configuration which is
the thing that you want to do and we
take care of all the productionization
so
the one that so rather than having to
write hundreds or even thousands of
lines of production code which of course
then needs to be maintained documented
tested you now do a single line and the
one that we have first launches run
inference no surprise given all the
excitement around machine learning and
in this space so run inference with a
single line of code we have done all our
encapsulated all of the things that I
described in the how to productionize a
a model within the beam Pipeline and you
as a user use that one line plus
providing a model Handler what is the
model Handler in this code well
it is simply configuration this is an
example of one this model Handler is
telling us that the model you are going
to use is a pi torch model it's location
in a Google Cloud Storage bucket and
some other information that's pertinent
to that particular model
since adding a run inference to uh beam
we've been continuously working it was
added early in mid last year we've been
adding features to it I can't go through
all of the features that are available
but I'll cherry-picked a few one is
support for lots of Frameworks so
obviously this is very key and we are
adding more and there is also something
known as a custom model Handler if your
particular framework isn't on this list
another thing we've added is support for
working with model repositories so if
you are using something from tensor Hub
or hugging face the configuration you
pass in in this case hugging phase
pipeline model Handler gives us the
ability to know what your intent is to
be able to pull the model onto the
workers
next is this is my favorite feature
um is streaming updates so in a machine
if you're training your machine learning
pipelines in your ml op systems you're
going to be continuously updating them
you're going to be making them better
and you want them to be deployed to your
streaming pipeline without having to
pause or create that pipeline so with
this feature when a new model arrives it
gets hot swapped on the data flow
service for you without having to pause
the the pipeline at all it supports two
modes one mode it's looking for the file
location if the file location the file
changes it's going to pull that model in
another mode is an event based mode
where for example you'll have in your ml
op system where you usually have a
pusher component your pusher component
can signal into the system that a new
model is available and it will go do the
necessary to pull that model from for
example the Google Cloud Storage bucket
okay so with these pieces we can
actually now do inference with very
little code
for our pipeline one of the things about
this particular pipeline is there's one
model and it's a very synchronous flow
which is of course some use cases but
many use cases are far more complex so I
had the great privilege of working with
the very clever engineers at Spotify
and here and this is in the public
domain in this blog we go over how there
are many machine learning models being
used and different Frameworks so in the
single pipeline they're just they're
using pi torch they're using tensorflow
to actually achieve their goal of uh
their business now how do we use run
inference
and the beam pipeline object to actually
build these complex flows
so let's take this spaghetti well
pipeline it really is spaghetti right if
we imagine each one of these blue boxes
is a model
the piece of data needs to run the
gauntlet of all these models before it
becomes useful to us how do we do this
well if you look at this there's a
couple of interesting characteristics
when we decompose it first all of the
arrows are pointing One Direction
therefore it's a directed A cyclograph
of computation and fits in with our
pipeline object second you'll notice
that actually there's only two patterns
that are continuously being repeated the
first pattern
given a piece of data in RP collection
we want that data to be have inference
run against it against two different
models what you'll notice on the code on
the right there's very little to do to
our pipeline object we simply apply two
different configurations for run
inference and we can achieve this
branching the next piece is sequential
models so here the data is being passed
to model one
the output of that is then being sent on
to another model for example you might
be extracting uh text from voice and
then you want to do some sentiment
analysis
um usually the output layer of the first
model is not in the right shape for the
input layer of the second model so you
usually put a mapping function in
between so here we have again on the
code on the right hand side very little
code needs to be written to describe
this path and if you repeat this you're
going to get back to that complex
spaghetti we saw in that first slide
so
um uh of course with inference
especially in a streaming system latency
matters even in a system where you know
you can tolerate one two minutes of
latency in a streaming system the
service rate of the transform that's
doing the inference needs to be able to
keep up with input otherwise you're just
going to get continuous backlog so often
you're going to make need a use of a
accelerator and again with the data flow
service I really haven't learned how to
do this I'll go forward
um this is also straightforward we
provide a option that we pass in on
Pipeline creation time as well as a
custom container that contains all the
dependencies that you have for your
images
um and this will install all of the
NVIDIA drivers on the worker as well as
the the exit the Nvidia GPU for you we
also work very closely with Nvidia we've
enabled Nvidia MPS which is allows for
more efficient context switching when
multiple python processors are vying for
that GPU time again if you imagine in
the streaming system the gpus in the
middle it's getting talked to by a lot
of python processors that are pulling in
work as they go forward
um
the other exciting thing so
uh up until this point we have been
talking about models that we are pulling
onto the dataflow worker for local
inference what if you are using a great
service like vertex I online predictions
which
um you know brings in all of the
Simplicity flexibility and assistiveness
for the that product's ability to deploy
machine learning models for you well
happy to announce that as of Apache beam
2.50 which is going to be released in
the next few weeks we uh we have a new
model Handler called the vertex that I
model Handler again this allows you to
make use of run inference but now with a
few lines of code you're connecting your
dataflow service to vertex AI online
predictions with no effort and we can
see customers making use of this in
mixed mode as well so imagine you have a
small model that you use earlier on in
your pipeline like in embedding model or
something like that and the next part
next call in that pipeline you're making
use of a very large model so there you
will mix the local inference with the
remote inference for the best inbreed of
your pipeline so with that there's quite
a couple of resources here for you you
can actually go on these links that are
fully working code lab examples for all
the things we've talked about today and
with that I'm going to pass over to Shan
thank you Reza
okay fantastic do we have audio here
okay I know we did a little bit of an
intro can you tell us a little bit about
yourself what you do and your uh you
know Etsy and and we will kick it off
that yeah so I'm a ml engineer on the
search ranking team at Etsy
Etsy is a global Marketplace for unique
and creative Goods you can buy
everything from like handmade earrings
to clothing to even Furniture so on my
team we train and deploy models to rank
items on search result pages so
basically when you type in a search
query and you get a bunch of items when
you see some things at the top and some
things at the bottom that's what my
team's responsible and we train our
models using tensorflow and we build our
pipelines on vertex AI with dataflow
okay that's that's great can you tell us
a little bit about severe you know the
key business priorities and sort of the
the path that you've taken so far yeah
so
um ranking is pretty important for
search Pages uh a lot of users only
really check the first few pages so
getting your ranking right is the
difference between someone bouncing or
converting so you really want to make
sure that um you got this right so one
really simple way to do it is uh
something called tfidf it comes bundled
in with a lot of Open Source search
engines like solar and this basically
what this does is this scores each item
in your search results set so when you
type in a search query it checks how
many times those query terms appear in
the object
and it gives also a little bit more
weight to rare items or to rare Awards
less common words
but this is a pretty simple scoring
mechanism and it's really easy to game
there's something called called keyword
stuffing so you might have gone on a
website before you notice like a product
title had like a hundred words in the
title because um the manufacturer or
seller is basically just trying to like
put in as much as they can so that they
can get in
to as many search results and for as
many searches as possible I deal with
that every day in Amazon yeah
so
um
we really want to look outside of this
realm of exact text matching and
optimize like for both the relevance but
also the likelihood of a customer
actually buying an item
so luckily
we have a lot of search sessions and we
log
um like what people search for the items
that we show them the product titles the
prices the review ratings things that
users have bought in the past and so on
so we have terabytes of data per day and
when you have all this data you know
someone in the room is going to bring up
let's use ml
okay very cool so you see them what
techniques do you use today and maybe if
you can give us a sense for our what
you've explored what you use today and
more importantly bringing it back to the
topic of the presentation how that has
influence your data architecture yeah so
our architecture
for our model has changed a couple of
times over the years we actually built
our first ml model in 2017 and the first
ml model for ranking in particular and
we just started off with the senior
simple linear model and we used Pi spark
for our feature engineering which uh for
those who don't know future engineering
is just taking your raw training data
then prepping it for for input to your
model
so yeah we use Pi spark and some
in-house in-house libraries for that as
we started to put more investment into
the ranking model we decided to switch
to a boosted tree model which
in in 2019 when we switched over to this
model was kind of the state of the art
for ranking at the time
and through many a b tests of our models
we were seeing increased engagement and
increase increased conversion but from
the development side for both our linear
and our trees model we were kind of
reaching a point of diminishing returns
we ran we were running out of ideas on
how to improve the model itself and we
ended up just doing more and more
feature engineering to try to improve
the performance of these ranking models
so lucky for us um around around 2019
2020 uh
deep learning has become more popular
become more popular in the ranking space
and there are papers being published
like every year on people on companies
figuring out how to use deep learning
and their ranking models
so
this was a good time for us
to also start investing in deep learning
and in 2021 that's when we started like
to put a lot more time into actually
investigating this
and while we were making the switch we
decided to re-look at our Pipeline and
make some changes in our our
architecture so we actually decided to
go with tensorflow for our model
training it's just a really mature
ecosystem for both training and
deployment to production and we also
decided to switch off of high spark onto
dataflow for our feature engineering uh
it just dataflow has a lot of
Integrations what tensorflow that makes
it easy to work with and also some of
the other benefits of moving to dataflow
was um I don't know if anyone's ever
managed a spark cluster before but it's
uh
yeah it's it can be very opaque to
people who don't understand or people
who have less experience in what's spark
but what data flow people are developers
could just focus on actually writing
python code and how the data flowed from
one place to another and in 2022 is when
we were actually able to launch our
neural ranking model as our Baseline
model in production in production yeah
very cool that that goes back to you
know the code samples that Reza was
showing on screen right how easy it is
to express your business logic with beam
yeah very cool so how does your data
architecture look like today we talked a
lot about your ml but walk us through
here sort of the overall architecture
for data today yeah so I have a pretty
simplified diagram of our Pipeline on
the slide here and basically all of our
training data is stored in GCS or Google
cloud storage and we use tensorflow
transform for our feature engineering so
tensorflow transform is a live area that
runs on on dataflow and allows you to
run tensorflow operations aggregations
in statistics on all of your raw
features and then put it in the correct
format for tensorflow to actually
understand and train with
we then pass those features over to our
training step which happens in vertex Ai
and we currently just train on one
server with multiple gpus on it and
after training we have the training step
generates a model artifact
so that model artifact will be what
eventually gets served in production but
also we take that model artifact and we
do an evaluation on it so for our
evaluation we actually also use data
flow so in data flow we can load in that
model artifact as well as loading in a
test data set from GCS and then run
inference on
using that test data set with the model
with the model loaded into dataflow and
then we calculate something called ndcg
which is basically just a metric to let
you know how well your ranking model is
performing
and every the nice thing about this
pipeline is every part of it is scalable
so as we get more data as we like as we
get more traffic and more data
all it just gets put into GCS and then
for our feature Engineering in our
evaluation we can just up the number of
workers to handle the additional the
additional traffic
and we are actually able to add workers
to our GPU training but we just haven't
found the need for that complexity yet
our training runs uh fine right now yeah
very cool let's now bring it back to
sort of the business benefits that you
talked about uh
yeah so to put quite simply uh the
benefit is just that search results are
better so one example is around
personalization
um so if you look at the screenshot on
the left this is what a new user might
see I basically just opened an incognito
tab and then I search earrings and this
is uh and this is what I got but then I
started to click around on specific
items I started to like add like wooden
things to my card add like some rustic
things to my cart and I did the search
for airing again so on the right side
you can see like the updated search
results so this is really catering to
like based on the user and what they're
searching we can show them what we
believe they want to purchase and this
is also a benefit for the sellers in our
Marketplace because they get exposed to
queries that they might have not been
exposed to before
and and overall as we've run our av
tests with our different models
we've seen increased search engagement
and increased conversion okay very cool
thanks for sharing appreciate it
hopefully the audience was able to get a
sense for how you've done it and your
your journey thank you very much for
your time
oh yeah so uh
are there any learnings or any takeaways
that you want to leave with the audience
uh yeah so the first thing I would do if
you're looking to use ml
is to do res look into the research and
the trends in your industry I think this
will help you like hit the ground
running and see what worked for other
companies and then see the things that
they struggled with
and also be prepared to fail it actually
took us about a year of iteration on our
neural ranking model to get it to a
state in which we felt comfortable
putting it into into production
so it can be a it can be a long process
but we felt the switch was was worth it
for all the benefits that came with deep
learning and ranking
and then
um just make incremental progress on
your models and learn and iterate from
any from like when you run tests and
things like that
and also really important is to build
your pipelines for scale so understand
where your data is now and where it
might be the future talk with your data
scientists your ml engineers and your
data Engineers to decide on like the
right solutions for how to make ml
models realistic for your use case
yeah fantastic thanksg
with that I think we'll switch gears and
talk a little bit about let me do a
quick time check I think we've got maybe
another three four minutes I'll do a
quick rundown of all the latest and
greatest capabilities and then we'll
open up for Q a we may not have enough
time to take all questions but we'll
hang out by the side or outside the room
so please find us if you have questions
so before I go in and talk about the new
capabilities to give you a little sense
for how we think about our roadmap and
where we invest in there are three key
areas that the team is really focused on
the first is what we think of as Best in
Class platform you know this in my mind
includes things like performance
scalability reliability and so on and so
forth this is the number one reason why
customers come to Google Cloud you know
particularly my product data flow and
this is an area that we we continue to
invest in we've launched a number of
capabilities in the last year I've got a
few that I'm personally very excited
about that I'll I'll quickly highlight
the second area of course is developer
experience and overall usability of the
product you know deploying you know
tuning operating and managing streaming
pipelines requires a different set of
tools than what you may have used for
batch pipelines so that's an area that
historically we've invested in and you
know we've got a number of capabilities
that I've highlight today and lastly you
know we want to make sure that you know
for Enterprise customers like you you
you're able to take our products our
platform and integrate that into your ID
systems your I.T policies be able to
meet your compliance needs either from
your own organization or Regulatory
Compliance requirements that you have so
we've launched number of capabilities
like support for shielded VMS
um you know support for confidential VMS
compliance with regulatory requirements
and so on so forth this is an area where
we want to stay lockstep with your
evolving needs as well
and then we talked about ml that sort of
all pervasive both in terms of giving
you capabilities to do your own Emma but
also applying ml to bring new
experiences new capabilities within the
product
so with that I'm going to quickly run
through a few you know exciting
capabilities the first is something
called Dynamic thread scaling this is
very unique in the industry we've been
able to bring that from if you recall I
talked about the product called Flume
which is used within Google so we are
able to bring this technique which
dynamically adjusts the number of
threads that are scheduled per core and
the and the objective here is to really
saturate CPU you know reduce cost for
you and get the most amount of juice
possible from the underlying resources
right of course you know we don't want
you know developers to go hand tune this
leads a lot of operational tile so we've
got a system where we can dynamically
you know adjust the number of cores that
are scheduled and then based on back
pressure are just that as needed
continuing on the theme of efficiency
you know some of you may know this
there's a component called streaming
engine which sits at the heart of
streaming and data flow which handles
all of the stateful computations and
streaming Shuffle there have been a
number of techniques a number of
enhancements that we've rolled out to
streaming engine in the in the recent
past I've highlighted some of those here
but most of those fall in the efficiency
theme right how do we automatically tune
the system based on your specific
pipeline based on your specific traffic
pattern so that we are able to optimize
the infrastructure for cost performance
latency and things like that
um on the developer experience side I
remember I told you how you know
deploying and managing uh streaming
pipelines require a different set of
tools uh you know we've got a number of
you know tools like you know uh our job
graph detailed dashboard monitoring
metrics one of the things that you do
not have until now is access to the
actual data that was passing through
your pipeline when a problem happened
right so we've got all sorts of
visualizations and dashboards today
where you can you can see where the
problem occurred but not what data was
being processed when that problem
occurred so with data sampling you now
have an automatic capability where
you're going to be able to see data that
was passing through your pipeline when a
problem happened
again to help with Diagnostics on
troubleshooting that's an area where I
see customers spend a lot of time right
so straggler detection is an automatic
capability that is going to identify
hotkeys or in general elements that are
slowing down here pipeline automatically
detect and in some cases not in all
cases in some cases give you the root
cause for stragglers and hotkeys in your
data
you know this has been a favorite ask
this year
um you know while the billing data that
is available as part of cloud billing is
the authoritative source for cost
information
asks where customers want to give their
individual practice practitioners the
ability to quickly look up costs so
we've now launched a job monitoring as
part of the data flow UI where you can
get a sense for what the estimated costs
for your jobs are going to be
with that I'm going to skip a couple of
slides actually let me highlight this
you know one of our developers you know
published a cookbook that has close to
190 samples for a lot of common use
cases it covers both Python and Java do
take a look at it and he's looking for
feedback and what else would be useful
as well it's all on GitHub
to wrap it up couple of other resources
you know there's a whole bunch of data
flow ml notebooks right which you can
just you know launch hit run and try it
for yourself and the second link QR code
takes you to our data flow get started
tutorials where there are a number of
tutorials depending on whether you're
new to data flow or you're an
experienced data flow user uh you could
take those for a spin
thank you